- There's a loop, I'm out of it.
I don't know anything about children.
- I currently don't have
any plans to have children
any time remotely soon, I'm
thinking maybe when I'm 50.
- My wife and I definitely want
kids, maybe some time soon.
- 2 1/2, I want 2 1/2.
- So you can have half of one of mine.
- One slightly smaller child.
- I'm just trying to take
care of my plants right now.
I'm not doing a very good job.
- What is the estimated annual cost
of having a single, five-year-old child?
- $16,210.
- $22,374.
- $30,106.
- Ooh.
- You gotta get their hair cut.
- Also shots.
- Five-year-olds shouldn't be drinking.
- I'm going A on this.
- C, a lot of money.
(bell chimes)
^ - [Voiceover] A.
- Yes.
- $16,000?
I can't afford a 28-year-old man.
- If they're this cheap,
10 minutes from now I might be like,
"Cool, I'm gonna get out
there and have five kids."
- According to the USDA,
United States Department of Agriculture,
the average percent of
household expenditures
attributable to one child is?
- 15%.
- 22%.
- 27%.
- Then you divide it by 15.
15, 30.
- My gut has been wrong both times so far,
but I'm gonna go with it again.
- It's roughly 20%.
- 22%.
(bell chimes)
^ - [Voiceover] C, 27%.
- This is rigged.
- I mean, I don't know.
These are some frickin' hard questions.
- What does the rest of that money go to?
- It's like car payments.
- Car payments, fish tanks.
Like adult fish tanks.
- What is the largest total expenditure
on a child in a two-children family?
- Health care.
- Child care/education.
- Housing.
- Any time I see a kid, I
just don't approach them
because they're usually
sneezing or coughing.
They do that kid cough.
- Kids are gross.
- B has never done me wrong,
except at the beginning.
So I'm sticking with B.
(bell chimes)
^ - [Voiceover] C, housing.
- Yes, woo, woo.
- What kind of houses
are people living in?
- Can't you just stack
the kids like Legos?
- I'm taking away your kids.
- What is the estimated
total cost of raising a child
up to 18, including all of
17, without college expenses?
- $245,000.
- $316,534.
- $372,812.
- Well, first of all, I just wanna say
all three of these numbers make me ill.
- 112 plus.
- Quarter of a million dollars.
It costs a quarter of a million dollars
to raise your child to the age of 18.
- The one goes up there.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
- Okay.
- $245,000.
- [Voiceover] It's A,
(bell chimes) $245,000.
- Oh, yes!
- You can get some really
nice shoes for $245,000.
- Yeah, you could.
- Maybe two pairs.
- So either go on a lot of vacations
or you don't go on vacation,
stick around the home,
have a bunch of little
yous running around,
they'll grow up, tell the world about you.
- I think I'm still
leaning towards vacation.
- Okay.
- [Man] I'm surprised,
it is really expensive.
- [Man 2] It's a decision
that you can't take lightly,
no matter what stage of
the process you're in.
- [Together] Thanks, Mom.
- You coulda had a Ferrari.